[Music]
back sandy blase hey folks
come on down welcome back hope you all
have had a great first day of faculty
summit I should thank of course first
and foremost the speakers from our
breakout sessions especially our
university partners who presented with
us
I thought the topics were top-notch and
I very much appreciate all of the
speakers for the evident care and effort
that they put into their presentations
there so thank you to all of the
breakout speakers we've got more to come
I'm particularly excited about the next
topic as I said this morning I thought
that was an amazing canvas of
opportunity in systems research and it's
not just for great research and
instruction I think there's an
opportunity for entrepreneurship as well
and we've got a panel of people who have
had success in translating their systems
research into entrepreneurial success
and I'm very pleased to introduce our
first panelist from Microsoft Research
Ranvir Chandra Ranbeer has a career at
Microsoft as a principal researcher he's
received himself over 85 patents here in
the US and more on the way he's been
running battery projects and TV white
spaces project he's probably best known
at the moment for running a project
called farm beats which is really an
internal start-up at Microsoft it
started as a research project in IOT for
digital agronomy and has moved now out
into customers hands and is making a
difference in reducing the cost and
increasing the viability of agriculture
as we face a future of increasing
scarcity he's been well recognized
published in a number of venues The
Economist Wall Street Journal
he's an MIT TR 35 where the technology
Beauty r35 winner is a top innovator and
so really has a lot to say about
entrepreneurship along with his two
co-panelists so with that let me
introduce Ranveer there you go
[Applause]
Thank You sandy and thank you all for
coming today we have an exciting 35
minutes where we have two distinguished
panelists will be discussing about
systems research and entrepreneurship
the two distinguished professors we have
one is dawn song from UC Berkeley and
matei from Stanford University welcome
Don
so both Dante are very well known
faculty they have both the dawn is a
professor at UC Berkeley she's her
papers are very well sited in addition
to that she's also received multiple
awards the MacArthur Fellowship the
Sloan fellowship the MIT T or 35 award
and the list goes on and on I won't go
there for this session what's exciting
is that she's done multiple startups
inside her security sold to fire I the
other one Mendel security and the third
one which he's doing right now is on
wasted slaps she does research in
security blockchain machine learning in
iCloud everything systems then a mattei
from Stanford University but a is young
faculty there he's already done amazing
work his PhD thesis was among the best
I've read in recent times which was on
Apache there this was this late Apache
spark which led to data breaks so he
released his code they're just not as
part of the PhD thesis which received
the ACM best dissertation award this was
released as open source since then he is
actually founded the startup which is
doing super well which raised which has
raised over two hundred and two hundred
million dollars and has several
customers and I sure it's on Azure as
well it's one of we course along with
data breaks so welcome again for this
exciting discussion so one of the things
as systems researchers we run into is
all of us who do research want to build
systems that is used by a lot of people
we want it to scale out we wanted to be
adopted out there in the wild there are
multiple ways to do that right all of us
at some point think that he know what
it's ready we are ready to take this out
and the few ways you can actually take
it out to multiple people is either you
can release it as open source my advice
kelvinator it's a recently did in a blog
on that whitey how do you when should
you open source your your solutions
either open source or you could license
it out there various faculty who've done
very well by licensing out the
technology like GUI so he from wisconsin
or the third which both of you have done
which is to do a startup so when did you
what meet you decide the one person ask
you this question since you've done one
startup after another when did you
decide that it was you were ready to do
a start-up and why startup why not
license it out or put your code out as
open source I think so different
researchers have different preferences
and for me I always feel that as a
researcher not only that I want to build
new technologies I'm really excited
about the innovation and from the
technical perspective and also at the
same time I feel as a researcher often
we do have the responsibility to take
our creations our new technologies into
the real world to help change the world
to help improve the world and with that
I think I enjoy the process of seeing
and also the the journey of taking the
technology that we developed in a lab
and actually into the real world to see
it also that's a great way as a first
hand and you can see what needs to be
improved in the technology that you have
developed and how to make it even better
and I think all these are great reasons
to actually do it firsthand and also as
technology innovators oftentimes you are
the one who actually understands the
technology best and hence you know
what's the best way to adjust and adapt
to the real world use cases and to find
the best product market fit no this is a
this is a good answer this is something
which propels me as well doing
previously with TV white spaces or with
farm beats success is not just writing a
paper it's actually getting it out into
the hands of everyone this is a
different principle for some faculty it
could just be a published two papers
someone will pick it up so metate to you
so you've done both you release your
code is open source which has been a big
hit and you're also doing a start-up
which is another big success so how did
you decide for each one of them which
route to go
and we do a decision of change like with
with spark would you still have released
it as open source of fact then you knew
that you were doing a startup yeah good
question
so in general so releasing software as
open source from researches is a great
way to see you know whether people can
actually use it and and also engage with
early users who are willing to try it
out and give you feedback so so that was
great I think for us one one reason to
start a company around it was actually
just to push it to the next level so
Apache spark already had a bunch of
early users when you know when we
decided to start the company and it had
some traction people were excited about
it but in a university you have limited
resources to work on it so we felt that
as a company we could actually you know
invest a lot more in it push it to the
next level and and tackle a whole new
set of problems with it and that's
exactly what happened actually since we
started the company both you know the
what's in the software like the
functionality that feature is have gone
to Amend ously and also the developer
community has gone tremendously and it's
definitely partly because the company
spent a lot of time making sure it's
super easy for people to use and to be
successful with so basically what you're
saying is depending on your idea
depending on what you're doing you might
want in some cases to open-source it
yeah even for example you created
courses around some of these right yeah
yeah so many people trained to use a
party spark yeah except lead to the
success of TWU yeah that's the thing the
company did to promote it and to help
people use that but it's it it is partly
a matter of scale as I said and it
depends on the software I mean this was
you know basically a distributed
computing platform and standard library
you know every data processing algorithm
you people you want to use giving you a
distributed version of it that's a
pretty big effort there are some other
efforts move maybe you just build a
small open-source project and its core
that way that's a good point so the
other question which is related to this
is how did you do the transition once
you wanted to do the startup how did you
go about doing it did you like in some
cases some academics are good at doing
research to you hi
someone from outside to be the CEO run
with it do you do it yourself
me how do you build a team at what point
because you set up students at what
point do you decide to take it out
versus just keep still doing research on
top building something solid and how do
you take it out how do you how do you
make it into a startup when do you
incorporate when do you build a start
about of it dawn why don't you start
with three experiences you have one
after another you could start with the
first one in cybersecurity
down to and now I'm doing the stage so I
do have a very broad experience in
industry courage and so in terms of
whether we should hire outside CEO
operating as a CEO or whether we should
do it ourselves so in my case actually
we've done both
so my first from a first company as well
as the third company the one that I'm
doing right now is his labs so I am the
CEO the founder and CEO and for the
second company man on security so that
one we actually have a grittier who has
been running us from very early on and I
think in different cases they actually
both have worked out really well so in
the first case and also for the third
one so essentially these are
technologies again informations one
thing is that for for technologies you
have as we develop technologies then
besides the technology science we also
really the biggest question is to find
product market fit and also the CEOs job
these besides you know hiring everything
money is to have to be able to carry out
the overall vision the direction for the
company so often times it's pretty
tricky for outside CEO who don't
understand a technology well enough to
actually lead the vision and also to
even find the compiler market fits
because they may not know the technology
enough to be able to quickly figure out
what may be the best product magic
market fit so in the first case in the
third case so I was able to allow the
CEO and and it was difficult to I mean I
was happy to do it and also it's hard to
find other CEOs to actually take to do
this and I think we were very lucky for
the
in case where I think just through
chances we were introduced through
friends and the CEO Amir and he has a
great track record he was already very
successful entrepreneur before who
instance to help that was acquired and
so on and and also the things that he
actually already was passionate about
the space that we were in the technology
that we were developing he was actually
thinking even something similar in that
domain so he already had a very good
understanding after space and his
background he has done a ton of
enterprise sales in his prior startups
so his background is a great fit in
terms of really actually helping to
define the problem market fit and also
to take the product really to enterprise
customers and really grow it and his
really excited really passionate and
committed to take the technology in a
fully going forward involvement is still
there as the technologists are also my
another
Brickley grad students we were together
on this technology and he actually has
been the co-founder and chief architects
of the technology so and he still as a
company and I said I think that really
viewers still the chief technologist you
add data Biggs how was your and your CEO
is again internal someone who was part
of the investment team so how did you
describe that experience mainly in the
context talk the audience who have who
are faculty
some of them might want to become
entrepreneurs or even licensed that idea
out or to hire people to take their
ideas to scale yeah well yeah I think
again I think the reason to do it
yourself is if you have a vision for it
maybe only you can execute or can can
see and it's really hard to you know get
someone else to do it and especially
also to hire someone who is very good to
do that because you know maybe it hasn't
been validated but you really believe in
it I think that's the reason to do it
my experience was a little different in
a few ways so one thing as I was just
finishing my PhD so I didn't have
my own research group at the time so
that made it easier to take some time
off completely and just work on the
startup and also we started with a bunch
of co-founders actually from the same
research group including you know my two
advisors and a lot of students and
Lagasse who is the CEO now who was a
visiting researcher working in
distributed system so we already had a
pretty tight-knit team that had worked
together for years and could could work
well together we definitely learned a
lot of stuff where we we had some people
on the team like Olli and yawns and
Scott who had startup experience and we
had others like me who didn't but we
also had enough I think you know we had
enough critical mass to build things and
to show promise of our idea and to be
able to hire the right people and the
other roles at the company wonderful so
then about raising money which is
related to this so when you're in the
valley but even then so a lot of
startups that we see are either business
model innovations these are the ones
that maybe in the social space there's
no technical meet behind it but for most
people in this audience these are really
strong technical contributions papers in
the top-tier conferences do you think
these kind of technical contributions
have been going out to VCS to raise
money is there
do you see making it easier for you to
to get into this space to do kickoff
let's start the process and in
particular dawn and wanted to ask you
we've been hearing a lot of comments
there are a lot of news articles around
women finding it hard women
entrepreneurs finding it hard to raise
money in the valley did you face any of
that do you have any recommendations for
female faculty in the audience who would
like to become entrepreneurs both
questions together right so maybe it's
easier for a female faculty because it's
coming with the technical background and
some suggestions that you might have
yeah I think it doesn't today and you
know like we do have an advantage there
are technologies that we already have
developed a unity of technologies and
usually when we start a company so in
all three cases there are technologies
that me and my group has developed in my
lab and we see the potential and we are
excited about the technology
and then we decided to do the company so
in this case unlike many in other
entrepreneurs we when we go out and we
actually already have the initial
technology that have already been
developed so that I think definitely
both from fundraising perspective and
also even from just being on a team
where they have a great team and the
core team are really passionately
excited about the technology that we're
having building in certain cases
realized for four years and so I think
that's a great start
that's like much you know a greater
starts than many of the the other types
of entrepreneurs companies as a women
entrepreneur I think so first of all so
we just forces labs we just with funding
reason today we made the announcement we
reached 45 million yeah thank you
and we also did in a very short period
of time and we had top of the line like
his great investors including Andreessen
and Excel and many other right investors
and so for me I think you I did I mean
it was a pretty smooth process and also
in particular I think actually as a
women entrepreneur we do have certain
advantages to in the sensor to actually
have you know quite a few friends who
are women like Reese's who run their
funds and also other you know other you
know male and this is who ran funds like
there are a number of them who actually
have strong you know intent and support
for women entrepreneurs that's pretty
good so in a fundraising I think I have
been lucky that people have the people
that I have seen they have been really
supportive for women entrepreneurs so
female faculty please reach out to dawn
for any recommendations of who to reach
out to yeah happy to help
yeah and metate do you have did you have
to do any fundraising yourself but it's
usually the CEO who does it
the investors yeah all the co-founders
were involved in it especially at the
beginning I think but I think - you know
who people who want to do it I mean I'll
say a couple of things so one thing is
anything you can do that shows
validation of your technology as in
someone would would actually buy it and
or even use it is it super important so
you know just having a paper at a top
conference they don't really know how to
judge it I mean they'll be happy to grab
coffee with you and talk because their
job is to go talk to lots of interesting
people and in the technology space but
you know they don't really know but if
you say ok there's someone using it
maybe someone in your university maybe
someone who use the open-source thing
and so on and they ask them and they
find it solving a real problem that
makes it a lot easier for them so for us
we had the open source you know spark
software and it was very easy for the
VCS to see that it's useful because a
lot of the portfolio companies were
already using it because they were
startup sutaio it's kind of crazy new
technology but that's that's what I
would go for and definitely if you you
know even if you don't know some some of
the top VCS you can I'm sure you know
other faculty members who know them and
you can get an introduction through them
and I think that will also carry a lot
of weight if someone they know says oh
you gotta talk to so-and-so because I
think they have something interesting
that's great feedbacks the users are
important do they have to be paying or
do they have to be do they have to at
least have paying potential or just demo
I think I think well they I think it's
good if they actually use that to to do
something valuable and you could ask
them is this actually valuable to you
they don't have to be paying but they
have to think it's it's useful so yeah
so a follow-up question which I think
would be in the mind of many of the
people in the audience is you guys are
running successful startups right now
both of them have raised quite a bit of
money how has any of this
entrepreneurship affected your research
career positively and negatively right
so both ways has how has it made your
research stronger or weaker what your
opinions done you could start you've
gone through three times and your
tenure do you have everything in the
Opera but you can say whatever you want
okay so I mean in general the answer of
course is positive I think again also
people to do things differently and
there are different jobs there I think
it's a very broad spectrum so in my case
also because my research area is really
broad the three startups they are
actually in very different areas the
first one was in mobile security the
second one was in secure browsing and
the third one is watching so and also
overall like my research is my research
is very proud so nonetheless I would say
in my case not necessarily the
particular technical things that I
learned from one company influenced the
next one because again to mention I
actually work in different areas but
what I would say is really the
experience that I have gained through
two industry hubs family I think that's
another reason that I actually enjoy it
I hope that I view it again I think many
of us here our growth minded like we're
here to really to grow to become better
and I think being a professor being a
researcher that's a great way for us to
learn and grow and on the other hand
being an entrepreneur is really it's a
great way to learn and grow and it's
very complementary to what we typically
do as a researcher as a faculty and
hence for that I think in general what
have benefited from the Entrepreneurship
experience is that it really helps me to
be stronger in this other dimension that
normally we don't get to exercise our
experience and our route that does help
provide a broader perspective when I
then choose research topics are when I
you know working
research and also in terms of also being
more effective I don't know because this
is a pattern in the startups that you do
you start a new research team get some
publications out do a startup get it
acquired or something
then come back to another research which
is great right you're scaling up your
research through startups mattei your
response to this discussion yeah I mean
I think for me being part of a startup
has been incredibly helpful in seeing
real world problems as they arise and
basically finding new research areas
that I know are important because I've
experienced the problem or like our
customers have experienced the problem
but that are maybe harder for people to
see or they even understand and in
academia some of them you probably can't
do at all unless you actually work with
with customers so I mean just a and
these can be very general problems there
are not specific to a particular
customer so just as an example database
sells only a cloud product is basically
software-as-a-service on Amazon Web
Services or Azure and the vast majority
of the revenue is just licensing fees of
using the software you know it's not
support or consulting or anything and so
it's got to build a really good software
as a service cloud product that's
multi-tenant and secure and performant
and highly available and building that
is really hard and this is actually the
way the vast majority of new enterprise
software today and even consumer
software software as a service and I
don't know any university class that
teaches you how to build it I don't see
any papers at conferences that actually
say hey here are the problems in terms
of building it or like here's a new
abstraction that you can use to deploy
SAS or whatever and it's it's just an
interesting thing to think about if you
if you know if people are going to keep
building computer systems in the future
this way we'd better understand how to
do it so a lot of the kind of you know
problems I think about in research are
inspired by that well I see ok something
was super hard like it literally took
three years to get right for database
it's gonna be hard for anyone else is
there any way to make that easier so
this is great so essentially what you're
saying is that both the startup
experience is helping enrich your
research career and so I'll bring up the
negative part of it ok so this is
slightly controversial there but in a
positive way that one of the questions I
asked both mattei and Dawn internally
was well
youth it's a full-time job running a
startup being in I'm doing being in
academia how do you manage it more than
were like well we spend 80% of the time
doing a start-up 80% of the time doing
academia so that's their time they'd
have zero time so my question here is
more around how do you manage time for
yourself not about research or startups
what is your me time and what do you do
in your meter and any tips for people
who want to do both and still have a me
time yeah dawn when you start that's a
very good question I wish there's a
there's a great answer to it because I
asked the same question like I think
especially subtractive right now with
the Oasis labs we are growing very fast
and there's really there's a lot of
excitement and we are talking to
actually a lot of potential customers
and so on and there's just so much to do
and right the day just how do you do
outside of work how do you relax
actually so earlier I was taking fencing
lessons that helps that helps even with
I just figured somehow I actually really
enjoyed those fencing sports and then on
weekends actually I do go running on the
beach when I when I can when I have time
yeah many tips from your site I know
it's even busier for you eight students
managing doing writing really quality
papers you're being very prolific I
think Don has a lot of students too yeah
she has she fences with them I mean my
feeling on this is even just a academic
job alone or just a startup
job alone can easily consume all your
time so in a sense you'd have the same
problem in either case and you have to
in both cases you have to you know be
mindful of your time understand you know
what's the best way for you to spend
stuff when should you take time off do
something else when should you delegate
when you know you should evaluate what
you're doing see you know is this
actually the right way
to spend my time what's actually most
important to spend time on so I think
it's it's not that different but you do
you know you have to expect that things
will be somewhat hectic and I think
anyone who does either of these two jobs
really enjoys them I don't think anyone
starts you know tenure-track faculty job
without enjoying that or startup for my
experience it's the same in a research
lab and I don't sitting in I'm telling
you this but it's we do it we work
extraord speakers we enjoy doing what we
do with the nice one beats project is
about we do it because we know
eventually it will help farmers and
that's why the entire team just works
the extra hours weekends getting things
up this is great
so now going to another question which
is around both of you who are very
successful as entrepreneurs and one is
from Berkeley the others from Stanford
and you're from Berkeley as well is
there something in the water of the
berry or the scarcity of water in the
Bay Area or is there something else that
makes that schools they're more
successful other things that other
schools could learn other than proximity
to the B C's that are there is there
something else that that the University
enables for faculty to do to do more
startups of really scale up startups
done I think the biggest thing it's it's
the ecosystems in salina BRE I think
there's a great ecosystem for doing
startups and also it's kind of the I
guess it's in mindsets and the people
that you interact with often they are I
guess the concentration of entrepreneur
you know minded people probably it's
very high in the Bay Area and of course
it has a great set of like the density
of species and and and all that and also
yes I think maybe there's also a little
bit of a self-selection among the VCS
you mean I'm even I think again I can
you know Bay Area people who like who go
to the area advisory yeah also there's a
bit similar itself selected
but what with Stanford we see so many of
them so what yeah I think so you see a
lot - yeah I was from Berkeley as well
you have to work people are yeah that's
that's yeah yeah I mean I being in the
Bay Area is definitely good for
connections and also for hiring people
who've been at startups and so on it
does help with that there are
communities and other cities and are
there a studio that can do it so it can
be done but it definitely helps I don't
know I mean I think the other thing is
having a supportive department and
department chair and so on but I think
most universities do want to see
successful startups come out of it but
you know you you want to make sure that
they let you do it that you're not
penalized in some way but support from
the department such as what well so for
example you know can you go and leave
for some time to do it can you go on
partial leave maybe because you have
students you want to continue supporting
them and doing research these types of
things sometimes it can be inflexible
because of what you know policies or
bureaucracy sometimes they'll push
through and make sure you know if they
think it's impactful that that you can
do it I think many universities try to
enable that related question so as big
companies as us here at Microsoft how
can we enable more such successful
entrepreneurs from various various
universities not just Berkeley and
Stanford but universities at other
places as well
would you have any suggestions on what
companies like Microsoft can do and so
pretty surprised give me my money and
also I think Microsoft is just I you
know any big company and she has a lot
of advantages or has a lot of value that
they can provide to future entrepreneurs
to faculty who want to become
entrepreneurs later so for example
Microsoft also sees a lot of problems so
I know switch problems
points for customers and which ones may
have a big banker that's actually new
technologies and I think faculty and
researchers are always always love to
learn about these type of problems and
also Microsoft has a great platform if
anyone develops a new technology
Microsoft has this offers a great
platform that can introduce this
technology to a lot of users and
companies and so on can really help a
new technology to to be to be adopted
and to grow and so I think that can that
can be really helpful and you add
something to that yeah I think beyond
funding which is definitely you know
super important both for research
actually in the areas you know that you
you think are impactful and for for
companies I think Microsoft is
interesting because it has wide reach
into enterprises and pretty much any
yeah so anything you know any sort of
business partnerships with startups will
be impactful and I think those already
exist in many areas of Microsoft maybe
people don't know how to approach those
or how to get one started but they they
do make a difference early on and they
can help you you know validate your idea
and be good basically for both sides of
the partnership so how can Microsoft
approach these so both of you said it'd
be great if we reach out but what is a
good medium to reach out to these
entrepreneurs to the startups is it
through courses students do you have any
suggestions or through some like how do
we engage better with such parting
startups and then maybe cool marketing
events or things like that maybe way so
while we're coming to the end of the
time just any parting thoughts on
faculty here who might be thinking about
taking their idea out and scaling it out
through a startup so don't yeah that's a
good question I think one is that I
think entrepreneurship there is
something really fun to try of course
it's also very hard one of those is
really it takes a lot of time and
it's yeah it's goodie you have to focus
a lot on it and and also like now to
every I think people like it do you know
we all write many papers but now every
single paper is necessarily something
that you may want to turn it into a
stratum so typically first and we want
technology that's both innovative so
that gives you an edge and also it needs
to be really practical enough that
actually can be used in the real world
so many papers that we write about it
has new ideas really really cool ideas
but it may still be at the very early
stage she does now practically enough
yet so those are probably not ready for
doing a start-up yet and also the theory
says I need to really solve a big enough
problem that people are willing to pay
for it has a big enough market and and I
think as faculty and researchers who are
looking at starting their company trying
to see which technology that they have
developed they may want to take you know
into the markets there's something
helpful to keep in mind yeah I mean I
think the reasons to to do it are
basically impact and also ability to
work on problems that maybe would be
harder to work on in academia so these
are these are both good reasons to do it
it is a lot of work as Don said and it's
a it's a large commitment and you know
you it will take more time than you
expect even if you take just a little
bit of time you know sabbatical whatever
and then you want to go back if things
are going well you'll want to continue
being involved and there'll be a lot of
things you can do so it is it is a
somewhat large commitment but on the
other hand you can really see things
that you wouldn't see outside and
especially if you find a good team and
you have you know investors or partners
who can help get things started they can
accelerate that because you know it's
also their job to help you make those
connections and and get those are the
users yeah yeah thank you thank you Matt
and Dawn and we'll be all in the bus for
dinner feel free to ask us questions
hope you enjoyed this
if you have any more questions we'd love
to carry on the discussion over dinner
thank you everyone thank you and Sandy
you